okay so lock and key season two is now
out on netflix and it has a really big
ending that we definitely need to talk
about whilst i thought that the first
season had a lot of filler in it the new
set of episodes really feel like they
have a purpose to them and through this
season we watches the lock family battle
it out against dodge and all his forces
we're going to be breaking it all down
but there will be heavy spoilers so if
you don't want anything ruined then i
recommend you like this video until
you've had the chance to see it please
like the breakdown if you enjoy it and
also subscribe if you think this channel
is a keeper like like a key terrible but
without the way thanks for clicking this
now let's get into lock and key season
two
okay so season one ended with a lock
family believing that they put dodge
back through the omega door
however in the final few scenes it was
revealed that dodge had used the
identity key on ellie to make it seem
like it was her the truth was that dodge
was also gabe and it was a pretty big
twist that completely changed the entire
series now it turned out that dodge's
plan had been to not only get some
whispering iron but he'd also managed to
bring a demon into the world who
possessed eden that takes us into the
second season and throughout it we watch
as the lox slowly learn the truth about
gabe and eden whilst the pair attempt to
make their own keys there's a lot of
things coming full circle from the first
season such as the movie premiere and
also aaron boss is finally freed from
her own mind i said aaron vos not eric
vos
the family also discovers several new
keys and each one of these comes with
its own abilities and powers after being
tricked by chamberlain lock gaben eden
discovered that the key to well making
keys lies with duncan after witnessing
his brother rendall killer possessed
lucas ali and co had removed his
memories and this season very much
centers around him taking a trip through
memory lane in order to regain the ones
that he lost for so long now on the flip
side of this we also see the heartbreak
that comes when certain characters start
to lose theirs as they get older adults
are unable to retain memories regarding
magic and this is very much shown in
jackie who starts to forget things as
she ages towards 18. there's definitely
a dementia and alzheimer's metaphor to
it and it's kind of heartbreaking
watching her slowly lose her happy
memories as she gets older tyler tries
to do anything he can for her to hold on
to them but it proves to be pretty
futile which is definitely something i'm
sure a lot of people can apply to their
own lives if they've seen an elderly
person go through it after taking a trip
into eden's head kinsey and scott
discover the truth not only about her
but also about gabe and they start to
plan an attack unfortunately aaron goes
out to do things herself and gets killed
by gabe in this process as she's unable
to dodge it now this kind of leads us
into the latter part of the season where
the locks and their friends try to
ambush gabe and eden but it ends up
going badly gabe retreats to a cabin in
the woods that he'd been using as a base
and with duncan he creates a new key
capable of turning people into demons
now this includes jackie and dodge was
able to do this because he struck people
who were completely unaware of what was
going on tragically jackie could have
been on the inside had she not refused
the opportunity to get her memories back
tyler seemingly finds a way to reverse
the spell after creating his own key but
this counteraction ends up killing her
in one of the season's most shocking
scenes turns out that if you kill the
demon that you kill the host too and it
pretty much puts the entire family on
the back foot add to this we see that
ellie is freed after bodhi josh and his
daughter jaime open the omega door
alongside eden now throughout the season
we also see flashbacks to the
revolutionary war namely the battle
between frederick gideon and ben lok
gideon ended up discovering the omega
portal and after becoming a demon he
terrorized the entire north shore this
plotline actually pulls from the graphic
novel namely the book clockworks and the
chapter the locksmith's son after
hearing more about him from josh eden
very much realizes that she wants gideon
on her side and this sets up what
happens at the end of the season now
gabe tells kinsey that he actually has
feelings for her and he offers a deal to
join his side kinsey goes to him the
next day to talk it out but this is
actually a distraction so that the rest
of the group can sneak into gabe's
lavish new house kinzie jumps off the
cliff side but this is when she reveals
that she's got a new key capable of
giving her wings the final episode is
called cliffhanger and it's a nice
little note to this action scene and
also the way that this season ends now
tyler's gotten duncan head into the
basement namely a vault to unlock it and
here they're struck by dodge's forces or
gabe's
dodge look it gets confusing now dodge
goes to tackle them and transforms back
into his original form i have to say
this actress was a really big miss in
the season and though griffin gluck did
an amazing job of portraying gabe i
would have loved to have seen her back
more throughout the 10 episodes now at
this point she commands her forces to
rush the locks in scott but because
duncan is the one who created the demon
key he actually has control over them
you should call him duncan go nuts
because he gets the demons to go nuts on
them
and as you can see that's kind of why
i've stopped doing as many bad puns
because they're all terrible now at key
house ellie arrives and proves that
she's not dodged by taking a key from
bodhi later on she's transformed back to
her original self with the identity one
and we'll talk about this more later on
in the video now as for dodge he or she
at this point uses the vine key which
causes the foundation of the house to be
destroyed dodging kinsey go head to head
as the house crumbles off the cliff edge
and it makes for an awesome final action
set piece though dodge gets the upper
hand kinsey is saved by her brother and
together they all tumble off the edge of
the cliff luckily because of kinsey's
wings she's able to pull tyler out and
we get a big turn up for the books when
lucas climbs up the cliffside it turns
out that the alpha key separated dodge
from him and because he's an echo he
didn't die during the process they
wonder whether he's good or bad but he
pretty much plays his hand when he
returns the keys to kinsey now ellie is
reunited with him and though she's a
she's a fair bit older now than when
they dated it seems that the two could
pick up where they left off the town
mourns the people that were killed in
the cliff collapse and fundraisers are
held for the victims families tyler then
takes some time out and decides to go
traveling during the winter break
clearly he's torn up about jackie and he
even ends up deleting the videos they
recorded together because he's
desperately trying to spare himself the
pain of her memory much like jackie he
refuses to use the memory key and the
character says that he wants to return
to a normal life it's a pretty sad
ending and now jackie is gone there is
potentially a way to bring her back
which we'll talk about later on in the
video now i really appreciated that they
took this narrative arc with tyler as it
thematically brings everything together
and shows that the pain of losing
someone can often push you to the point
you wish you'd never met them
duncan gives him the keys to the car the
pair has stored together and tyler gives
the family the keys in order to keep
them safe tyler hits the road and ellie
is reunited with rufus kinsey throws a
going away party for scott and we learn
that he's moving to manchester to start
a film course bodhi goes to his mother
and gives her the head key which finally
fills her in on exactly what's going on
in her mind she comes across all her
favorite memories including the ones of
her deceased husband randall she even
does a bun in the oven joke to announce
she's pregnant or as we call it at the
channel a pun in the oven hey how am i
now the trip down memory lane helps her
to remember all of the good times and
body gives her the memory key to make
sure that all these moments remain in
place
now though lucas made it gabe didn't and
after his body doesn't turn up it's
presumed he's dead however because eden
wasn't in the final confrontation she's
still out in the world she discovers the
echo key stashed in gabe's room and
returns to the world to free captain
gideon after saying his name he steps
forward as an echo but because he can't
cross the threshold eden ends up using
the anywhere key to open a gateway so
that he can escape eden's master plan is
for him to return to the portal and open
it once more as doing it with josh
caused a lot of issues though eden wants
him to follow her he takes the put me
down literally and then drops her down
the well now gideon is obviously going
to be the big bad for the next season
and he will no doubt try and restart the
carnage that he was stopped from
carrying out originally this is actually
a big turn up for the books or well from
the books as this didn't happen in the
source material and it's a massive
deviation that's gonna take things in a
brand new direction i think he will
travel to the portal himself and then
try and bring forth an army but there
might be other villains in the mix that
attempt to either join forces with him
or stop him so that they can take over
kevin durant is obviously a pretty big
actor for the show and though i do think
that he'll be the main one there are
other potential evil forces out there
now the first of those is ally though i
think that she is probably a good person
we don't know what happened to her while
she was trapped in the plane of lengths
she could have come out the other side
as a demon and though i think that's an
unlikely theory it is still definitely
one that's worth talking about there's
also the possibility that eden isn't
dead either and if the locks return to
the well house they could end up finding
out from her the truth about gideon eden
has pretty much been screwed over by
every single demon that she's tried to
help so i think it would be really
interesting if she ended up joining with
the locks in order to stop him now the
final villain could indeed be dodge or
other gabe now i am going to spoil one
of the major arcs in the comics so if
you don't want to know then skip ahead
to our review part as this could
potentially ruin the future seasons for
you are you gone are they gone yeah
bunch of idiots aren't there thanks for
sticking with me i know you guys are the
real heavy spoilers fans you're the real
fans now in the comics dodge actually
ends up taking over bodies body at one
point after he vacates it possessing
this gives him complete access to the
house and it's a really good plot twist
now they end up finding this out
eventually and they kill dodge which in
turn sheds him from bodhi's body
unfortunately bodhi dies because of this
and his corpse is then cremated before
his spirit can return to it however
tyler manages to bring the character
back to life after restoring his
physical form so if they end up going
this route there is a way the character
can return now i'm not sure if they will
do this in the show it does make it
clear that characters can come back i
actually think they might even change
this plot up somewhat and have dodge
enter jackie's body and then possess her
if tyler forgets everything then she can
pretty much still manipulate the
character and get him to unwittingly
bring all the keys to her they could
then have something similar to the body
plot with her dying and then tyler may
resurrect her which could close out the
show season 3 has already been greenlit
so we know it's coming and i'd love to
see them do that in the next entry now
as for my thoughts on the series i was
someone who quite enjoyed the first
season but i wasn't completely blown
away by it i scored it a 7 out of 10 and
that's because i found that there was a
lot of filler episodes that were based
around the structure of finding a key
seeing what it does and that was pretty
much it there wasn't that much plot
progression until the last couple of
episodes and when something is nearly 10
hours long that means it can drag out
quite a bit however i found this season
way more interesting there's just so
much more purpose to the entire thing
and having this setup out the way means
that they can hit the ground running
this makes for a much more interesting
show and instead of discovering what the
keys do we are now seeing the group use
them i also found the relationships far
more fleshed out as well knowing gabe
was dodge now helped to make the scenes
he had with kinsey even more tense and
there was a lot of suspense throughout
the seasons purely because of this add
to it the complexities of tyler and
jackie's relationship and you have a
much more engaging storyline in my
opinion there's also some really dark
things in this entry too and to me it
just improved on the first season in
every single way and that doesn't mean
it's perfect either and there are still
some plotting elements i am very much of
the mind that they could cut this down
by two episodes per season and still
have the same amount of plot in eight
but they seem committed to the ten
episode run however i did enjoy what we
got and overall i'm gonna score it an
eight out of ten now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the show so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are running competition right
now and giving away three copies of the
phase 3 mcu boxset on the 30th of
october all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the show we pick the
comments at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you they're
messaging me on twitter heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
june which will be linked on screen
right now i know a lot of you got
questions over exactly what's going on
in the film so we've tried to explain
them as clearly as possible if not then
thank you for sticking through this
video i hope you enjoy the rest of your
weekend you take care of yourself and
i'll see you on the next one peace